hello everyone welcome to the tutorial
for database link with Wolfram language
this tutorial is made up of three parts
we will go through each one of them in
detail
let's start with part 1 in this part we
will know about what database link is
some of the key features of database
link how does it work how to make
connections to your database using this
package how to set it up how to
configure a connection and about a
little GUI that we have which is that
called database Explorer a little bit
about security and authentication so
database link is a package that provides
functions that helps you establish
connection between Wolfram language and
your database involved from language
this is a toolkit in which we call as we
should also call as a package now any
function that you would perform on a
database engine you can perform that
using database link some of the key
features of database link are it works
with a wide variety of sequel databases
it comes with a lightweight database
which is H sequel DB most of the listed
database engines here which is my sequel
sequel server oracle Postgres are
compatible with this package mostly a
sequel and we'll both Wolfram language
commands can be used with this package
there is a GUI called as database
Explorer which is a very basic GUI that
you can use it also supports batch
operations which is good for when having
large amounts of data if you want to
insert huge amounts of data this is a
very good option and it also supports
several database types like numbers
strings binary data date time and
Wolfram language expressions so apart
from the regular types there are special
data types that are built into the
language and will
go through them one by one so let's
first see how this package actually
works so here we have a small diagram
depicting the flow when you issue a
Wolfram language command to perform a
database operation so what lies in
between the database and your Wolfram
language layer is a Java layer here we
use one of our other Wolfram language
technology called as jailing which
communicates with the database and also
with the top Wolfram language layer the
part that communicates with the database
which is the Java layer here does it
through this JDBC that's why we have in
our database link package you have the
JDBC drivers that are bundled up here so
once you hit shift enter with the
command the command just goes to this
Java layer and then it gets executed it
gets the data from the database and
comes back to Wolfram language layer
where it can be used it's like a list of
data and where it can be used with other
Wolfram language functions like plots or
for numerical analysis or data modeling
etc now because we have commands that
you can use in word Straw sequel and
Wolfram language it is a very convenient
tool like if you are not very familiar
with sequel language you can just follow
the Wolfram language commands which are
pretty into intuitive and it's easy to
use and on the other hand let's say if
you're not very familiar with Wolfram
language but you're good at sequel that
works fine too
so there is there are functions where
you can actually provide just the raw
sequel command and that works as well
now let's see where this database link
sits in the installation so if you
evaluate this command here it opens up
this directory which is called database
link and if you have Mathematica
installed you can evaluate this
and this will open up this particular
directory here and inside this you can
see that there is a Java directory and a
kernel directory and that's where the
source code for database links its so
this is all the Java classes and this is
all the Wolfram language side of it so
if you want to do a little experiment on
your own you can also modify this source
files little bit and then reload the
package and see what effect it has now
let's see how we make connections to the
database so since this is a package
within Wolfram language it needs to be
loaded in your current kernel session
first so to do that we issue this
command called needs database link this
will load the package into your current
session now to do that there as I
already said that there is there are
some JDBC drivers that are bundled with
database link now we have to make sure
that these drivers are on the path or on
the class path to be recognizable by
database link by default they are
already added to the path so you don't
have to do add to class path or anything
to make them available on the path
however if you find that there is a
database that you want to use for which
a JDBC driver is not included in the
package you can always download that and
add it up in several locations within
your Mathematica installation one such
location is this dollar user base
directory and another location is this
base directory and all the other current
drivers actually sit in the dollar
installation directory and this is
another place where you can add it as
now that we have loaded the package we
want to connect to a database called as
demo this demo database comes with Mac
Marika it's a very lightweight database
built upon each sequel DB and you don't
have to configure anything to to work
with this database and where you open a
connection to this database is using
this open sequel connection command and
just give the name of the database
so once you do that you get this sequel
connection object it is basically a Java
object so if I do connection full form
you can see that in generally this is
just a Java object that it created for
communication between Wolfram language
and the database now at any point if you
want to know what are the current open
connections you can evaluate sequel
connections I already opened a few
connections so that you can see the
output of this one that there are four
connections to currently open and at any
point if you want to see what are the
properties of a particular open
connection you can use sequel connection
information now this sequel connection
information gives a lot of information
so I'm suppressing the output here by
putting a semicolon but you can always
take a look at its short form so these
are the properties for which it will
tell you what are the values set for
that connection and there is a about 167
of them now if you want to close the
connection close equal connection and
just give the connection object and that
will close the current open connection
now in the previous example we saw that
we're opening a connection to an already
built in database and that is already
configured and we don't have to put a
server name or a username or password or
any other properties that we would
rather use in a connection string now
let's say if you want to use those all
those properties and open a connection
then you can provide some extra
arguments to open sequel connection for
example here you can see that I'm
providing the name of the database
engine and providing the database to
which I want to open a connection and a
name and a user name so let's try that
opens a connection here another example
that more commonly used is with my
sequel connection now this will this my
sequel database it's on my local machine
and it's called test DB and the machine
is localhost and I'm providing a
username and password now my sequel
connection J this is the name of the
configuration file that sits in database
link now this configuration file
consists of all the connection details
in it if you go to the database link
user guide you will be able to see how
to confirm it how to configure a
connection how to make this
configuration file and put it at a
location which is recognizable by
database link now here if you notice for
password I have a dollar prompt in there
and which means that when I evaluate
this it should prompt up a window for me
to enter the password rather than just
typing the password in the notebook here
so that's the prompt we get I'm gonna
enter my password here and that makes a
connection to test DB so this dollar
prompt is useful if you don't want the
password to show up for C
confidentiality reasons
now there is also a graphical user
interface which is built into database
link and this is a very very basic form
of the interface it's it's something
that beginners can use and to get
familiar with you know how database link
is working and how to select something
from table and do very simple operations
let me show you an example here so you
can evaluate this database Explorer
command this is the window that comes up
and I can make a connection to any of
the configurations that I've already
saved now this will show me what tables
the demo database has and what columns
it has and if I so currently the table
selected a sample table one and the
column that selected is entry if I just
click on result it's going to select
everything from entry now there is also
a connection tool which is called the
opens sequel connection tool and that is
just the connection part of the previous
database Explorer that we saw so if
let's say if you want if you want to
establish a connection more frequently
to a certain database and you want to
save its configuration in a file you can
do that and have your connections listed
here so once you open this click on
let's say demo and connect it's just
going to give you a connection object
same as by putting all the arguments
within open secure connection now let's
go to the security and authentication
part which is one of the most important
parts when you are working with a
database so if your database supports
SSL it is possible for database link to
talk to the database through SSL there
are some steps that need to be followed
and the four major ones are listed here
the first one is to get a certificate of
authority and then generate a trust
stork file then you need to configure
the Java that you are using to use that
trust or file and then configure your
opens
connection to use the ssl let me open up
the documentation and show you a little
more detail about this one so this is a
more comprehensive documentation on
using ssl and here's an example using
Postgres sequel so here we are creating
a certificate called CA dot c RT it's a
sample certificate and then we are just
creating a trust store file here now you
want to add that trust or file to your
current Java JVM arguments and that's
done that which is what is done here and
when you're doing the open sequel
connection you can either provide this
as a query parameter where an SSL is set
to true or you can use properties option
within open sequel connection and set
SSL to true now this will let you use as
a cell with database link but you have
to be sure that your database supports
SSL in the first place now there are
several tips that you can use to make
your operations secure you can use a
connection configuration file and you
can always encode that file so that the
connection configuration is not readable
easily readable by any third party and
you can use dollar prompt as I showed
you before
and if you're using a web server you can
also use the authentication mechanism
provided by the web server and
Mathematica will retrieve the password
from the server and the details for all
of this is available in the database
user guide here are some resources for
you to go through these are the
connections parts of database
connections and resources documentation
is available here and it tells you all
the different functions that relate to
making and configuring a connection
there is also a documentation on
database Explorer it's a little more
detail than what we saw and also
includes the
recommendation on connection tool and
how to query the database using this
tool so this brings us to the end of
part one next we will be going on to
part two which will show how to use
different commands to query the database